[Music]  where do we begin here ago these cops  and lawyers wouldn't dare cross any of  you I mean what happened so what are you  proposing it's simple  kill the Batman here's my card  Bruce this is Harvey Dent Rachel's told  me everything about you I most certainly  am NOT  you wants told me that we'd be together  did you mean it  Grayson don't make me your only hope  like your outfit right that's right sir  a psychotic ex-boyfriends I should be  aware of you might have no idea  good evening ladies and gentlemen  here tonight's entertainment hello  beautiful  you look nervous I've seen now would  have to become to stop men like him the  night is darkest just before the dawn I  promise you the dawn is coming  the city deserves a better class of  criminal I'm gonna give it dog  now  you see  to either die a hero or you live long  enough to see yourself become the  villain  will you be one in the back picture  little the day Alfred number so the  Lamborghini did much more subtle